hey I'm Olivia Rodrigo and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
all right when did Olivia Rodrigo become
famous I was acting on shows when I was
younger I was very fortunate to be in a
few Disney shows and that was so much
fun and then I put out driver's license
when I was 17 and sort of changed my
world forever so maybe I'd say driver's
license simultaneously everything
changed in my life and nothing changed
at all feel the same I hang out with the
same people I still have the same
insecurities and fears I feel like I'm
good at the same things it's just my
environment just changed completely in
such a short amount of time
kind of crazy looking back on it I'm
like wow what a wild time when did
Olivia Rodrigo get her drivers license
I got my driver's license a little late
I think I was 17. all my friends were
getting their driver's license driving
around I would literally go to bed like
thinking about it dreaming about it and
I booked an appointment to go to the DMV
to take my test and I take my mom's car
and I pull up and the test proctor or
whatever is in the other seat and he's
like okay like left right stop blinker
works okay brake lights work great and
he goes honk the horn and I try to honk
the horn and nothing comes out and I'm
like what like that's so weird he's like
we'll try again I keep trying to keep
trying and the horn doesn't work on my
mom's car for some reason and they say
oh you're unfit like you can't take the
test your car's unsafe and I cry like a
baby in the parking lot I was so
distraught but then the second time that
I took the test I got a song out of it
too so I'd say that it was probably
meant to be
why does Olivia Rodrigo make sad songs
that's fun people like to listen to sad
songs I love listening to sad songs even
when I'm happy and they're really fun to
write when I'm really low and I listen
to a sad song that I absolutely love
that captures that feeling really
succinctly it just helps you understand
you're feeling so much more and that's
just in and of itself so powerful I love
sad songs I'll love them forever who is
Olivia's songs about
your mom
all right can Olivia Rodrigo parallel
park guys wrote a song and I said I
can't parallel park in the song I was 18
then I'm 20 now and I actually think
that I am quite passable I did it the
other day on a crowded busy street where
there are people behind me really
putting pressure on me and I was so
proud of myself and I what my friend was
in the passenger seat to witness so one
of my crowning achievements is Olivia
Rodrigo
favorite color purple yes my favorite
color is purple I like it it's a color
of magic and all things Mystic
it's a little red we go friends with
Jenna Ortega yes I am Jenna and I grew
up together on the Disney Channel which
is a very strange way to grow up but
I've always thought she was the coolest
and so happy for her and all of her
success I truly don't know anyone more
kind or deserving is Olivia Rodrigo a
good singer I hope so God I'm no Mariah
Carey or anything but I like to think
that I convey some emotion in my voice
and that's what counts hope so
how does Olivia Rodrigo write songs I'm
a very lyric based songwriter I love
looking at songs as if they're just like
pieces of poetry so lots of times uh
inspiration for my songs will come
across I always someone will be saying
something interesting in a conversation
I'll be like wow that's cool that's
catchy that that rhymes like let me
write that down every time it's
different sometimes I'll come up with
chords or Melody that I like and finish
it from there it's what's fun about it
you never know you never know how it's
gonna happen how old was Olivia Rodrigo
in high school
in high school oh I was like um High
school-ish uh High School Musical that
makes way more sense
um must have been 15.
how to draw Olivia Rodrigo easy I'm not
the person to ask here I'll give you a
template I think I have like sort of
heart-shaped face I could be wrong oh
God okay I have like almondy eyes this
is just already super bad okay this is
gonna be more of a Picasso
oh God that looks awful I tried to draw
me sticking my tongue out to try to like
remake the sour cover so that it was
clear it was me but
it looks terrible I write songs I don't
draw I tried
all right
what is Olivia Rodrigo's genre I'd like
to think that I make pop music that is
adventurous I love rock music and folk
music and singer songwriter music
obviously there's a little bit of
sprinkles of that in there what song did
Olivia Rodrigo change the lyrics to
change the lyrics to a lot of songs I
suppose on sour it was very angsty
um and so lots of the songs on sour
didn't really change too much from the
sort of original Inception of of the
idea but I guess on this album I did a
lot more
polishing so every song always changing
what is Olivia Rodriguez most streamed
song driver's license and good for you
it's good for you wow that's cool thanks
guys
um good for you I think I was rightfully
really nervous that I was gonna be one
hit wonder nothing wrong with being a
one hit wonder I was so happy to have
that one hit when I had it but
um it was really cool to see that good
for you in some regards better than
driver's license that was really cool
um grateful for everyone who has
streamed those songs thank you so much
what is Olivia Rodrigo vampire about
Olivia Rodrigo vampire is about me
because all my songs are about me and
they're introspective and they're about
nothing else
okay will Olivia Rodrigo do a guts tour
yes I will I'm very excited come see me
it would be a lot of fun I'm so excited
for this tour I think it's going to be a
ball does Olivia Rodrigo have a tattoo
it's debatable I got a matching tattoo
with my best friend Iris we got hearts
on our pinkies and I don't know if you
can tell mine is completely worn off it
doesn't look like a heart at all it
looks like I like smudged Sharpie on my
hand or something like that so
technically there is some tattoo ink but
I don't know if I'd really classify it
as a tattoo I think my next tattoo I'm
gonna wait till I have kids and then
I'll get their names tattooed on me or
something like that that's the plan does
Olivia Rodrigo say I love you in deja vu
I do say I love you in deja vu if you
listen very closely I go love you in
between the chorus and the verse and
then I go I love you because it's
between the chorus and the verse but you
have to turn it up really loud to hear
it little secret from me to you okay oh
Olivia Rodrigo album cover yeah I mean I
have two albums they both have purple
album covers this latest one has some
rings that
um say guts on them because I love four
letter words all types of four letter
words and uh hope you like it yeah
Olivia Rodrigo College I took a poetry
class so that was really fun and we
actually turned one of the songs that I
wrote In The Poetry class the poem is
called Lacey which turned it into a song
on that album called Lacey so it was a
quite fruitful Olivia Rodrigo Jack White
he's great he's one of my heroes so go
Jack White I think the white stripes are
so perfectly simple and so grungy and
imperfect in the most beautiful
intentional way and he just like writes
the catchiest riffs and hooks and I
don't know how he does it it's like
otherworldly Olivia Rodrigo quotes from
songs I don't know there's there's kind
of a lot to choose from I see brutal
lyrics a lot people tell me that it's
brutal out here a lot good for you every
time I meet a new person they're like oh
um so maybe that okay Olivia Rodrigo's
zodiac sign I'm a Pisces through and
through baby Pisces are like super
emotional super musical they like water
usually and I love water if I'm ever
stressed out I'll like jump in a pool
with the ocean or even going in the
shower and I'm just reborn I don't know
cool
okay what is Olivia Rodrigo's new album
called my album is called the guts I
came up with the name many years ago I
wrote a song that is not very good and
we'll never see the light of day called
hate your guts and I always thought that
was a really interesting phrase
um and I also love that guts can mean
bravery trusting your gut means
intuition you know spilling your guts is
telling everyone your little secrets so
a very loaded word and I like it
what is Olivia Rodrigo's nickname lots
of people call me live
some people call me Livy my mom calls me
Livy Lou Bell my grandpa calls me Oli
you know not terribly unusual what's
Olivia Rodrigo's aesthetic God you know
some days I really don't know
um I really love 90s sort of grungy
things PJ Harvey style I love Alexa
Chung style TBD on that one I feel like
I'm ever changing over evolving what is
Olivia Rodriguez
daily routine lately I've been waking up
every day I've been making a matcha and
eating two Brazil nuts because I saw
some Tick Tock that's something that's
good for your hormones or something
which is probably like a complete lie
but
um try to write every day every day is
different so I always start that off my
matcha and my two Brazil months what
shampoo does Olivia Rodrigo use it's
called Good Hair Day someone gave it to
me once and I just went with it rolling
with it
those are all the boards so glad I could
clear the air on what type of shampoo I
use I know you guys were dying to now
burning question now I feel like I need
to go learn how to draw
thank you so much for watching